This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. At the end of World War II, as the world began to process the powerful and devastating effects of the bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki, humankind entered a new era, an era defined by the destructive potential of nuclear weapons and the global arms race to acquire them. And while the violent applications of atomic research had already been proven, governments and scientists suspected atomic science also held promise for good. Peaceful applications that could bring the world into a new age of scientific progress and technology. It is not enough to take this weapon out of the hands of the soldier.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。第二次世界大战结束时，随着世界开始意识到广岛和长崎原子弹轰炸所带来的强大而毁灭性的影响，全人类进入了一个新时代——一个由核武器的破坏潜力以及各国为获取核武器而展开的全球军备竞赛所定义的时代。虽然原子研究的暴力应用已经得到了证实，但政府和科学家们怀疑，原子科学同样孕育着造福人类的希望。这些和平利用的途径能够引领世界进入科学与技术进步的新时代。把这种武器从士兵手中夺走是远远不够的。
It must be put into the hands of those who will know how to strip its military casing and adapt it to the arts of peace. That's President Dwight Eisenhower addressing the UN in a 1953 speech titled, Adams for Peace. In it, he proposes creating an agency to oversee and promote safe, secure, and peaceful nuclear technologies while also continuing to build up the United States arsenal of nuclear weapons. That agency, created in 1957, was called the International Atomic Energy Association. Experts would be mobilized to apply atomic energy to the needs of agriculture, medicine, and other peaceful activities. These efforts to find peaceful applications for nuclear research would spur growth in
必须把它交到那些知道如何剥离其军事外壳并将其改造成和平艺术的人手中。这是美国总统德怀特·艾森豪威尔在 1953 年联合国演讲中发表的讲话，题为《原子能和平利用》。在演讲中，他提议建立一个机构来监督和推广安全、可靠且和平的核技术，同时继续扩充美国的核武器库。这个成立于 1957 年的机构被称为国际原子能机构。专家们将被动员起来，将原子能应用于农业、医学和其他和平活动的需求。这些为核研究寻找和平应用的努力将推动……的发展。
nuclear energy, which now provides around a fifth of the United States electricity, and expand the use of nuclear medicine, giving us imaging techniques and therapies still used for cancer treatments today. That's our own Sherefusif. But then there were ideas that seemed kind of crazy in hindsight. One science writer thought nuclear alchemy was possible, though we would have nuclear factories that manufactured gold. He also believed we could create artificial suns to control the weather, and others believed we could shower plants and ionizing
核能目前提供了美国大约五分之一的电力，并扩大了核医学的应用，为我们提供了至今仍用于癌症治疗的成像技术和疗法。这是我们的谢里·优素福。然而，事后回想起来，当时有些想法显得有点疯狂。一位科普作家认为核炼金术是可能的，尽管我们会拥有制造黄金的核工厂。他还相信我们可以创造人造太阳来控制天气，其他人则相信我们可以用电离辐射喷淋植物，将其突变成更好、更强壮的作物。但与其他人不同的是，那一个确实发生了。
radiation, to mutate them into better, stronger crops. But unlike the others, that one actually happened. When I ran across it, I was just kind of gopsmacked, you know, I was just stunned, and then just so surprised. I mean, there was very little scholarly writing about it. That's Paige Johnson. I'm a chemist and material scientist. I have a hobby of the history of gardens. Johnson is one of the few experts on the often forgotten atomic gardens of the 1950s and
当我偶然发现它时，我简直惊呆了你知道的，我只是震惊，然后感到无比惊讶。我的意思是，关于它的学术著作非常少。那是佩吉·约翰逊。我是一名化学家和材料科学家。我有研究园林历史的爱好。约翰逊是关于 50 年代和 60 年代那些经常被遗忘的原子园林的少数专家之一。
60s. Gardens that used radioactive materials and attempts to mutate and breed new plants that would benefit mankind. People kind of assume it was some sort of a conspiracy. You know, oh, this was all hidden from the public, wasn't it? And this was a part of the CIA or it was a part of the propaganda agencies, or that sort of thing. And actually, it wasn't.
这些花园利用放射性物质，试图通过突变培育出造福人类的新植物。人们总觉得这某种程度上是个阴谋。你知道的，哦，这一切都对公众隐瞒了，不是吗？这是中央情报局的一部分，或者是宣传机构的一部分，诸如此类。而实际上，并非如此。
It was widely talked about in speeches. It was written about in popular magazines. Atomic gardens have been largely forgotten, but they weren't top secret government projects purposely obscured from us. They were right out in the open, and they produced new kinds of fruits and grains and vegetables that we still have
人们在演讲中广泛谈论它。它被写进通俗杂志里。原子花园在很大程度上已经被遗忘，但它们并不是故意对我们隐瞒的最高机密政府项目。它们就大白于天下，并且它们培育出了我们今天依然能在杂货店货架上买到的新品种水果、谷物和蔬菜。
on our grocery store shelves today. The atomic gardens of the 1950s and 60s were part of a broader interest in atomic research that ramped up during and after World War II, but they were also part of a much older quest, to breed better, harder crops. Humans have been messing with plants to suit our needs for a long time, but to understand the history of using radiation to mutate plants, we need to take a step back to the 1920s, and a relatively new technology of the time. X-rays In 1927, Herman Muller conducted a famous genetics experiment where he exposed fruit flies to x-rays, a form of ionizing radiation. So basically ionizing radiation is just any form of electromagnetic radiation that has
20 世纪 50 和 60 年代的原子花园是二战期间及之后加剧的对原子研究更广泛兴趣的一部分，但它们也是一个更古老的追求的一部分——培育更好、更抗逆的作物。人类为了满足自身需求而摆弄植物已经有很长一段时间了，但要理解利用辐射使植物发生突变的历史，我们需要将时间倒回 20 世纪 20 年代，以及当时一项相对新技术——X 射线。1927 年，赫尔曼·穆勒进行了一项著名的遗传学实验，他将果蝇暴露在 X 射线（一种电离辐射）下。所以基本上电离辐射就是任何形式的电磁辐射，它具有穿透物质的能力，因此有能力潜在地进入细胞内部并真正改变遗传物质。
the power to penetrate matter, so it has the ability to potentially go inside the cell and actually alter the genetic material. The x-rays change the genetic makeup of some of the fruit flies, and some of those changes those mutations were heritable, meaning that they could be passed along to the next generation. In the 1920s and 30s, some plant breeders started using X-rays on plants, and hopes that they could induce mutations that could make them grow faster or produce more fruit or create interesting flowers. But enthusiasm for those techniques would soon die down.
X 射线改变了部分果蝇的基因构成，其中一些改变（即突变）是可以遗传的，这意味着它们可以传递给下一代。在 20 世纪 20 年代和 30 年代，一些植物育种家开始对植物使用 X 射线，希望能够诱发突变，使其生长更快、产出更多果实或培育出有趣的奇花异草。但对这些技术的热情很快就消退了。
And for a while, the world lost interest in how radiation could alter plants. Fast forward to World War II, in a top-secret mission spearheaded by the US government, the Medhaton Project. engineers was established to administer work on military uses of uranium. The US began doing research not only on how to make atomic bonds, but what their effects might be after detonation. In concert with the kind of weapon-based experiments, they had started to kind of try to monitor what the effect of the nuclear radiation and fallout would be on plants and animals as well. That research continued after the war in a project called Operation Crossroads where the
有一段时间，世界对辐射如何改变植物失去了兴趣。快进到第二次世界大战，在由美国政府牵头的一项最高机密任务——曼哈顿计划中，工程师们被派去管理关于铀的军事用途的工作。美国不仅开始研究如何制造原子弹，还研究它们在引爆后可能会产生什么影响。在进行类似基于武器的实验的同时，他们也开始着手监测核辐射和放射性沉降物对动植物的影响。这项研究在战后的一项名为“十字路口行动”的项目中得以继续，在该项目中，
US tested nuclear bombs around a small cluster of islands in the Pacific. The bikini atoll is where the US was testing the atomic bombs, not in the middle of the ocean. And that's the first place where they really start intentionally planting plants and seeing how they're affected. Researchers wanted to find out how plants would respond to the heat and the gamma rays that the bombs gave off. The U.S. also docked boats nearby, filled with rats and goats and pigs to see the effects of bombs on living animals. A lot of them died, from the blast as well as the radiation. But there are other strains of nuclear research going on much closer to home, particularly
美国在太平洋的一小群岛屿周围测试了核弹。比基尼环礁是美国测试原子弹的地方，而不是在海洋正中央。那是他们真正开始有意种植植物并观察它们如何受到影响的第一个地方。研究人员想要弄清楚植物将如何对原子弹散发出的热量和伽马射线做出反应。美国还在附近停泊了装满老鼠、山羊和猪的船只，以观察原子弹对活体动物的影响。其中许多动物死于爆炸以及辐射。但在离家更近的地方，特别是在……
in national labs where the government was willing to throw funding at the new hot topic of nuclear science. Even if those projects weren't directly related to weapons. Enter the atomic gardens, and a new quest to alter genetic material and plants. Something we're still doing today. With modern genetic modification techniques, we have the ability to go in and very carefully slice the genome with a scalpel. The radiation experiments the atomic gardens were essentially just hitting the genome with a hammer and seeing what would happen.
国家实验室里，政府愿意将资金投入核科学这个新的热门话题，即使这些项目与武器没有直接关系，也有其他种类的核研究正在进行。原子花园应运而生，开启了改变基因材料和植物的新追求。这是我们今天仍在做的事情。通过现代基因改造技术，我们可以用手术刀进入并非常小心地切割基因组。而原子花园中的辐射实验本质上只是用锤子敲击基因组，看看会发生什么。
One of the most fascinating examples of this research was happening at Brookhaven National Labs. So the Gama Gardens of Brookhaven in New York were probably the largest gardens in the US governmental effort devoted to the atomic radiation of plants. The Brookhaven Gama Garden was created in 1949. And its original goal was to study the effects of prolonged exposure to gamma rays on plants.
这项研究最引人入胜的例子之一发生在布鲁克海汶国家实验室。因此，纽约布鲁克海汶的伽马花园可能是美国政府致力于植物原子辐射努力中最大的花园。布鲁克海汶伽马花园创建于 1949 年。其最初的目标是研究长期暴露于伽马射线对植物的影响。
But eventually, they began to research whether they can use gamma gardens to induce beneficial mutations. The essence of a gamma garden is it looks like a big circle with pie-shaped wedges, and at the very center of the pie is a radioactive source that was usually contained in a pole and would be raised above the level of the ground. To call them gardens actually makes them sound smaller than they were. Many of these gamma gardens were five acres in size, so they were really massive installations. And because of the wedges, when viewed from above, it almost looks like the symbol for radiation danger. The center pole contained a radioactive isotope, usually cobalt-60, that would shower the field with gamma radiation for about 20 hours a day. When it was time for researchers to
但最终，他们开始研究是否可以利用伽马花园来诱导有益的突变。伽马花园的本质看起来像一个带有扇形楔的大圆圈，而在扇形的中心是一个放射源，通常装在一个柱子里，并且会被提升到地面以上的高度。把它们称为花园其实让它们听起来比实际尺寸要小。许多这样的伽马花园面积达五英亩，所以它们真的是巨大的设施。正因为这些扇形楔，从上方俯瞰时，它看起来几乎就像辐射危险的标志。中心柱包含一个放射性同位素（通常是钴-60），它会每天向田地喷射伽马辐射约 20 小时。当研究人员需要……
go in and see the results, they would lower the source into an underground bunker made of concrete or lead, step inside the field's high fence, and inspect the plants arrayed around the center. Generally, at the very front of the source, almost all those plants would die pretty much, or they'd be shrunken and shriveled. As you got back towards the back of the pie shaped wedge, you'd see plants that were living that might look normal, but which were going to be evaluated to see if they had any abnormal growth patterns. Mutations naturally randomly occur in every living cell, but here the researchers were
进去查看结果时，他们会把放射源降入一个由混凝土或铅制成的地下掩体中，走进场地的高栅栏内，检查排列在中心周围的植物。通常在放射源的正前方，几乎所有这些植物基本上都会死掉，或者它们会变得萎缩和枯萎。当你向扇形楔的后方走去时，你会看到活着的植物，它们看起来可能很正常，但将被评估它们是否有任何异常生长模式。突变在每个活细胞中都会自然随机地发生，但在这里，研究人员是……
hand-rearing the plans with radiation in an attempt to increase that rate of mutation in the plans DNA, so in a sense the scientists hoped to speed up evolution. They were hoping to create crops that could withstand harsh growing conditions that were more resistant to disease that could produce more food to help feed the world. I was struck again by just what a utopian quest it was to kind of rebuild plants and end world famine and make the world they even used this language as smiling garden of Eden. And this quest wasn't just taking place in the US. By the late 1950s, similar
用辐射人工培育植物，试图提高植物 DNA 中的突变率，因此从某种意义上说，科学家们希望加速进化。他们希望能培育出能够抵御恶劣生长条件、对疾病更有抵抗力、能够生产更多食物以帮助养活世界的作物。我又一次被这种试图重建植物、终结世界饥荒并将世界变成——他们甚至使用了“微笑的伊甸园”这样的语言——的乌托邦式追求所震撼。这种追求不仅发生在美国。到 20 世纪 50 年代末，类似的……
experiments were happening around the world. In Norway, Sweden, Costa Rica, and the Soviet Union, among other places. And not all of these efforts were run by the government or fancy research universities. Some were done by curious citizens. The Adams for Peace Movement began to support the idea that home experimenters could run their own nuclear projects. As part of this Adams for Peace effort, it was really actually designed to enable atomic entrepreneurship as well, which seemed startling.
实验正在世界各地进行。其中包括挪威、瑞典、哥斯达黎加和苏联等地。而且这些努力并非全部由政府或高级研究大学主导。有些是由好奇的公民完成的。“原子和平运动”开始支持业余实验者可以开展他们自己的核项目的想法。作为这项“原子和平”努力的一部分，它实际上确实旨在支持原子创业精神，这看起来令人震惊。
You know, it's like kind of if the startup culture of today existed, only you could get a radioactive source from the government, with which to run your startup company. In the late 1950s, an oral surgeon in Tennessee became one of these atomic entrepreneurs. His name was CJ Spees, and he built a little bunker in his backyard where he started irradiating seeds and selling them to home gardeners and to children looking for science fair projects. These irradiated seeds weren't dangerous to handle, just because something's been irradiated doesn't make it radioactive. One of Spies' biggest clients was an English woman named Muriel
你知道的，这就像当今的创业文化如果存在的话，只是你可以从政府那里得到一个放射源来经营你的初创公司。在 20 世纪 50 年代末，田纳西州的一名口腔外科医生成为了这些原子企业家之一。他的名字叫 CJ·斯皮斯，他在自己的后院建了一个小掩体，在那里他开始辐照种子，并将它们出售给家庭园丁和寻找科学博览会项目的孩子们。这些被辐照过的种子处理起来并不危险，因为某物被辐照过并不意味着它具有放射性。斯皮斯最大的客户之一是一位名叫穆里尔的英国女性……
Howard, who was an enthusiast of all things atomic, and all things gardening. She formed something called the Atomic Gardening Society. And its purpose was really to engage the lay gardener in the sorts of atomic experiments that were taking place in the national laboratories. So she wanted to provide them with irradiated seeds, and they would hopefully discover useful mutations in people's backyards. People could become members of her atomic gardening society, and mural would ship out the irradiated seeds and ask them to send back any data they could about the plants.
霍华德，她是一位狂热的原子迷和园艺迷。她成立了一个名为“原子园艺协会”的组织。其真正目的是让业余园丁参与到国家实验室正在进行的这种原子实验中。因此，她希望为他们提供辐照种子，希望他们能在人们的后院发现有用的突变。人们可以成为她的原子园艺协会的会员，穆里尔会寄出辐照种子，并请他们寄回他们能收集到的关于这些植物的任何数据。
This was really an early example of crowdsourcing science was what she was doing. And her atomic gardening society was just one of Howard's efforts to get people involved and interested in nuclear science. Previous to the forming the atomic gardening society, she had published something called the atomic digest, whose byline was safeguarding the atom for the layman. That digest was part of another society she started,
这确实是她所做的科学众包的一个早期例子。她的原子园艺协会只是霍华德让人们参与并对核科学产生兴趣的努力之一。在成立原子园艺协会之前，她曾出版过一本名为《原子文摘》的刊物，其副标题是“为外行人守护原子”。该文摘是她发起的另一个协会的一部分，
called the atomic society for the layman. Albert Einstein agrees to be the first patron of her society. She was invited to gatherings of the Nobel laureates who acknowledged her who say our goals are much like yours. A lot of atomic scientists liked the idea that their work was being used for something besides making bombs. So the atomic scientists were very concerned that the power of the atom would be kept kind of only
名为“外行人原子协会”。阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦同意担任她协会的第一位赞助人。她被邀请参加诺贝尔奖得主的聚会，诺贝尔奖得主们对她表示认可，并说我们的目标和你们的很相似。许多原子科学家很喜欢这样一个想法，即他们的工作除了制造炸弹之外还能用于其他事情。因此，原子科学家非常担心原子的力量会被保留下来用于邪恶和武器制造，并认为最安全的途径是将其带到阳光下，带到外行人的领域，带到这些更和平的事业中。穆里尔当然为这一事业做出了巨大努力。她举办了许多原子聚会和活动，例如播放有关原子主题的电影、举办讲座、举办派对，而她的独特之处在于她明确地与女性谈论此事。1950 年，她甚至上演了一场精心编排的表演，演员们以哑剧形式表现原子的基本结构，
for evil and only for weaponry and felt like the safest route for it was for it to be brought out into the open and into the realm of the layperson and into these more peaceful causes. And Miriel certainly made great efforts to help this cause. She had a lot of atomic gatherings and events, so there were film screenings, about atomic topics, there were lectures, there were parties, and she was particularly unique in that she spoke explicitly to women about this. In 1950, she even staged an elaborate performance in which actors pantomined the basic structure of an atom,
并受到一些主要出版物的评论。以下是《时代》杂志对这场表演的评论。在由 250 名着迷的女士和十多位略显无聊的绅士组成的精选观众面前，大约 13 位身材丰满的原子能女伴身着飘逸的晚礼服，在舞台上优雅地旋转，真诚地模仿着工作中原子力量的运作。
and it was reviewed by some pretty major publications. So here is the review of the performance in Time magazine. Before a select audience of 250 wrapped ladies and a dozen faintly bored gentlemen, some 13 busomy atomic energy associates in flowing evening gowns gyrated gracefully about a stage in earnest imitation of atomic forces at work.
到了 20 世纪 60 年代，公众对原子园艺的热情逐渐消退。原子园艺协会的成员们厌倦了从他们的种子中看到极少有希望的结果。获得有益突变的情况极其罕见，而且对于没有科学培训背景的人来说，突变很难察觉。后院原子园艺基本上随着穆里尔·霍华德达到了顶峰。但辐射植物育种并没有完全消失。日本有一个研究所，使用与布鲁克海汶伽马花园非常相似的辐射场，
By the 1960s, popular interest in atomic gardening was coming to an end. Members of the Atomic Gardening Society grew tired of seeing very few promising results from their seeds. It was extremely rare to get a beneficial mutation, and mutations were hard for people without scientific training to detect. Backyard atomic gardening basically reached its peak with Muriel Howarth. But radiation plant breeding didn't completely disappear. Japan has an institute that uses a radiation field very similar to the Brookhaven Gamigardens,
国际原子能机构和联合国粮食及农业组织拥有一个联合植物育种团队，至今仍在进行辐射研究。在我们的食物系统中，依然存在着源于辐射实验的植物品种，例如意大利的一种硬粒小麦品种、全亚洲的水稻品种、日本的某些梨品种以及美国的向日葵品种，这只是举几个例子。此外，里约星红柚也是由于辐射育种实验而诞生的，现在占得克萨斯州种植的红柚总量的大约 75%。
and the International Atomic Energy Association and the Food and Agriculture Organization of the United Nations have a joint plant breeding team, still conducting research with radiation today. And there are still varieties of plants in our food system that came about from radiation experiments, a strain of Durham wheat in Italy, varieties of rice throughout Asia, certain pairs in Japan, and a breed of sunflower in the US, just to name a few. Also, the Rio Star grapefruit came about because of radiation breeding experiments, and now accounts for about 75% of the grapefruit grown in Texas.
制作人德兰尼·霍尔过去住在得克萨斯州，可以证实它确实很美味。是的，我可以证实它确实很美味。尽管取得了一些成功，但辐射植物育种从未能兑现其终结饥荒并将世界变成所谓“微笑的伊甸园”的理想。基本上，在 60 年代之后，很明显事情并没有兑现它们的承诺。它绝对没有达到其抱负。那是海伦·柯里。
A producer, Delaney Hall, used to live in Texas and can confirm that it is delicious. Yeah, I can confirm that it is delicious. But despite some successes, radiation plant breeding never managed to live up to its ideals of ending famine and turning the world into a quote, smiling garden of Eden. Basically, after the 60s, it was clear that things didn't live up to their promise. It definitely didn't live up to its aspirations. That's Helen and Curry.
我是剑桥大学科学历史与哲学高级讲师。她也是《按需定制进化：20世纪美国的植物育种与技术创新》一书的作者。柯里认为，随着时间的推移，特别是在环保主义运动兴起之后，人们可能对所有与核相关的事物（包括辐射育种）不那么好奇，反而更加警惕。无论它是否会在田野里创造出可怕的东西
I'm a senior lecturer in the history and philosophy of science at the University of Cambridge. She's also the author of Evolution Made to Order, Plant, Breeding, and Technological Innovation in 20th century America. Curry thinks that over time, especially as environmentalist movements started, people may have become less intrigued by and more wary of all things new clear, including radiation breathing. Whether it's gonna create horrible things
而我可能无论如何都不想吃，我想知道辐射是否会残留在我吃的种子上并对我构成威胁。所以我认为，对于这些可能性是什么，这种看法变得更加复杂。一些历史学家认为，“原子和平”运动本来就只是个幌子，是在美国继续扩充核武库的同时，为原子研究披上一层积极外衣的一种方式。当艾森豪威尔于 1953 年就职时，美国拥有大约 1,000 枚核武器。
in the field that I might not wanna ever eat anyway, I wonder if radiation lingers on the seeds and might pose a threat to me. So I think this view becomes much more mixed about what the possibilities are. Some historians believe that the atoms for Peace movement was just a cover anyway, a way to put a positive spin on atomic research as the US continued to build up its nuclear arsenal. When Eisenhower assumed office in 1953, the US had about 1,000 nuclear weapons.
当他在 1961 年卸任时，这一数字达到了约 18,000 枚。艾森豪威尔需要人们相信核研究中存在希望，而不仅仅是恐惧，这样我们就不会完全背弃核武器。他希望我们继续追求核技术，即使它让我们感到害怕，因为苏联人肯定在追求它，而这在当时甚至更可怕。但这种走向相互保证毁灭的步伐也给我们留下了其他改变世界的非军事创新。比如核能、不断扩大的核医学领域，当然还有无可争议的美味——里约星红柚。
When he left in 1961, there were around 18,000. Eisenhower needed people to believe that there was hope in nuclear research, not just fear, so that we wouldn't turn away from nuclear weapons completely. He wanted us to keep pursuing nuclear technology even if it scared us, because the Soviets were certainly pursuing it, and that was even scarier at the time. But this march toward mutually assured destruction would leave us with other world-changing non-military innovations, too. Like nuclear power, the expanded field of nuclear medicine, and, of course, the unarugably delicious, Rio Star grapefruit.
佩吉·约翰逊运营着“花园历史女孩”博客和纳米技术公司 109 Tech。她还在收集后院原子花园的口述历史，所以如果你或你认识的人种过受辐射的种子，请访问 atomicgardenane.com 分享你的故事。如果你想了解更多关于辐射育种历史的知识，以及一些我们无法塞进这个故事的各种酷炫内容，请查看海伦·柯里的书《按需定制进化：20世纪美国的植物育种与技术创新》。该书由芝加哥大学出版社出版，你也可以在亚马逊上找到它。这本书真的很棒。99% Invisible 本周由谢里·优素福制作。
Paid Johnson runs the blog Garden History Girl and the Nano Technology Company 109 Tech. She's also collecting oral histories of the backyard atomic gardens, so if you or someone you know, planted some irradiated seeds, go to atomicgardenane.com to add your story. If you want to learn more about the history of radiation breeding, as well as a bunch of other cool stuff that we couldn't fit into this story, check out Helen Curry's book Evolution Made to Order, Plant Breeding in Technological Innovation in 20th Century America. It's available from University of Chicago Press, and you can also find it on Amazon. It's really good. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Shereefusive
与德兰尼·霍尔、埃弗里·特鲁夫曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、萨姆·格林斯潘以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。凯蒂·明格是我们高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们数字总监。塔伦·马兹是我们的办公室经理，肖恩·里亚尔为本集创作了所有原创音乐。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，产自美丽加州奥克兰市中心电台街的广播室。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我，账号是 Roman Mars，也可以@节目，账号是 99PI Orc。我们在 Instagram 和 Tumblr 上也有账号。但是如果你需要回顾我们在弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特周所做的一切，或者了解……
With Delaney Hall, Avery Trouffman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. Katie Mingle is our senior editor, Kurt Colstead is our digital director. Taren Mazze is our office manager and Sean Rial composed all original music for this episode. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Orc. We're on Instagram and Tumblr too. But if you need to catch up with all the stuff we did for Frank Lloyd Wright Week or learn
如何正确调整汽车后视镜（那是本周一篇非常受欢迎的文章），你必须访问 99pi.org。来自 PRX 的 Radio Tepi。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
how to properly adjust your car mirrors, that was a really popular article this week. You have to go to 99pi.org. Radio Tepi from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如何正确调节汽车后视镜，这是本周非常受欢迎的一篇文章。你必须访问99pi.org。来自PRX的Radio Tepi。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。